was i hurt by it yes but at the same
time i'm like
i've done nothing i've never done one
thing and i've been the most honest and
truthful and best friend to all of them
larsa pippen's dishing all the details
about the end of her friendship with kim
kardashian
and let's just say she's pointing the
finger right
at kim's hubby kanye west he literally
has brainwashed the whole family into
thinking that like
i don't even know what i don't even know
et has reached out to kim and kanye for
comment
things first started back in july kim
and her famous sisters chloe and
courtney
unfollowed larsa on social media which
was a big deal because
at the time she was kim's long time bff
we need to get more
she's appeared on keeping up with the
kardashians a lot over the years
i talk now larsa is speaking out
revealing what went down during a chat
with the hollywood raw podcast
i just feel like kanye was in a place
where he you know he
really didn't trust anyone with kim
when the 46 year old was asked if
something went down between her and
kanye that sparked the fallout
she said nope no we always had a great
relationship i just i don't know
people are not happy people are trying
to figure out their own i feel like
they want to put pressure and blame
other people for their situation and
you know i've seen that happen so much
that it's like i get it you know what i
mean i understand i get it like
is it hurtful one thousand percent it's
hurtful that people think like i hooked
up
like i'm trying to ruin like chloe's
life oh yeah
get this larsa also shot down those
rumors that she hooked up with chloe's
man
tristan thompson i'm like dude i would
never do that
like you know that's not even my
personality my personality is all about
love and support and i've been there and
i've supported them through
everything but the former real
housewives of miami star
did share this interesting backstory she
said she was dating tristan
before him and coco were a thing before
chloe or any of them even knew he
existed
i was seeing him i had him come to la i
brought him to
uh a party kim had i introduced him to
all of them
and then a week later maybe 10 days
later he started seeing chloe
which is fine i don't even care she's
even rooting for chloe and tristan
i applaud them for working things out i
think it's great that they're trying to
work on their relationship i'm
really proud of them okay so then
seriously what the heck happened
he literally has brainwashed the whole
family into thinking that like i
don't even know what i don't even know
he talks so much about me
being this that and this and that and i
feel like i ran into travis scott one
night at a club and travis called kylie
and said
that i was hitting on him and that never
happened so then that was like oh
well connie said she's this and then she
was sitting on travis and i'm like
by the way that never happened i came in
luck with the same people i came with
that
never freaking happened larsa seems just
as confused
as us she even claims that she was
kanye's go-to
friend to talk to he used to call me at
four five and six o'clock in the morning
and i was like the person that would
take his calls at four five and six in
the morning when he wanted to rant
how that turned maybe because
you know i blocked him on my phone
because i just couldn't bear taking his
calls anymore i was just like i
got cam drained so i blocked him on my
phone so
he obviously that really upset him so
then he turned that into like oh
she's this and she's that and then like
they all started to like
ride his wave up on this or on that so
what would larsa say to kanye now
if kanye feels like kim and you know him
are better without me
then let them be without me i'm okay
with that i have my
do i look like i'm suffering do i look
like i'm in pain i'm okay i will survive
was it hurtful yes but do i have love
from a lot of other places yes
so this shall pass too